pero no me den france24 me acompaña en
el estudio daniel hablando daniela buena
noche bienvenida comenzamos costa rica y
panamá no hicieron formalmente una
disputa comercial ante la organización
mundial de comercio de que se trate y
por qué colorados muy buenas noches mire
el lío consiste en que desde mediados de
2020 la mayoría de productos lácteos y
cárnicos costarricenses no pueden
ingresar a panamá por un lado este país
dice que su contraparte no está
cumpliendo con las medidas sanitarias
mientras que costa rica denuncia un
bloqueo comercial todo llegó a manos de
la organización mundial del comercio que
aclaró que la disputa tiene que ver
específicamente con la importación de
productos como fresas lácteos productos
cárnicos piñas y bananos de costa rica
panamá ahora estos países entran en un
periodo de dos meses para negociar de lo
contrario se tendrán que someter a lo
que diga este organismo multilateral y
cambiamos información porque los grandes
bancos de eeuu comenzaron ya a
recuperarse pues tres de ellos
presentaron sus resultados financieros
que mostraron que en todo 2020 bajaron
sus
significativamente pero al mismo tiempo
pues no perdieron la buena noticia para
ellos es que si tuvieron un muy buen
cuarto trimestre y haití morgan que es
el más grande también fue al que mejor
le fue en 2020 sus ganancias subieron un
42% hasta un récord de más de 12 mil
millones de dólares le sigue wells fargo
que subió sus utilidades en 4% se
acercaron a los 3 mil millones de
dólares y las de citigroup aunque
bajaron frente a un año atrás si fueron
mejores que en el trimestre anterior el
resultado inmediato raúl es que estos
bancos ya están comenzando a meter en
sus balances esos préstamos que la gente
estaba dejando de pagar y que ahora sí
lo están haciendo así es a nivel y
donald trump tensa las relaciones
comerciales con méxico antes de dejar su
mandato hay una carta del 11 de enero
que se dio a conocer este viernes en la
que altos funcionarios de la
administración trump como el propio mike
pompeo se quejan de que las políticas de
inversión del gobierno mexicano no son
las mejores
en concreto hablan de la incertidumbre
en la regulación del sector energético
porque supuestamente se han dado
instrucciones
a bloquear permisos a quienes quieren
ejecutar proyectos privados y advierten
que esto puede violar las normas del
acuerdo comercial que entró en vigencia
en julio del año pasado de estos dos
países con canadá el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador por su parte se
defendió y dijo que ese tratado pues se
habían comprometido a respetar las
normas constitucionales de cada país y
que por lo tanto no se estaba violando
este pacto daniela y vamos con otro con
otro tema porque en europa están cerca
de aprobar el consumo de derivados de
los insectos así como lo oye raúl solo
falta que lo autorice la comisión
europea y este tipo de productos
específicamente el gusano amarillo de la
harina estarán en los platos suculentos
europeos un grupo francés quiere secar
el gusano para elaborar alimentos y la
agencia europea de seguridad alimentaria
considera que comer ese insecto seco es
el seguro porque tiene proteínas grasas
y fibra pues mejor dejemos que sea un
vocero de la entidad quien lo explica
la primera formulación y la larva entera
blanqueada y secada térmicamente sin
palabras simples larvas secas
[Música]
y la segunda formulación es un polvo
seco que se obtiene triturando estas
larvas secas suárez anglos aplican por
ejemplo el solicitante quiero utilizar
este insecto en polvo como ingrediente
en la producción de galletas
sin whisky y no solamente son galletas
también es pasta algunos alimentos a
base de legumbres e incluso barras
energéticas imitaciones de carne y hasta
bebidas se eliminan los el emigrado yo
creería que sí y daniela y pues si es
por el planeta mejor indicadores oeste
del cerro en rojo una semana de malos
datos macroeconómicos y en medio del
anuncio de que habrá más estímulos que
por ahora solamente es un anuncio en
europa las bolsas de se movieron a la
baja más pendiente de la expansión sobre
la pandemia en especial en china y
américa latina también se tiñó de rojo
con un retroceso significativo en sao
paulo para finalizar que nos trae como
cifra el día
1100 millones de dólares que consiguió
hoy en bolsa mercado libre que es la
empresa latinoamericana más valiosa lo
hizo a través de una emisión de bonos es
decir papeles que compran los
inversionistas ya cambio reciben un
interés por varios años
concretamente 2026 y 2031
daniela como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica a ustedes también
gracias continua con nosotros y feliz
noche
[Música]